كيف علمت علمتي او في اي فتره علمتي ان
السلطات او اشتكيتي من ان السلطات حولتك
الى ايه دعايات قالت دعايه سياسيه ضد
المعسكر الاخر
وهو يتعلق بالمره الاولى التي رايت فيها
الصوره عندما انتشرت الصوره كنت في
المستشفى ثم لما عدت الى قريه اران والدي
اياها وقال لي هذه صورتك ومثل ما شرحت لك
فقد سالت والدي بغضب لماذا التقط صوره
هكذا ولماذا نشرها في الوقت الذي كنت
عاريه مع شقيقه واقاربي لماذا لم يتفهم
هؤلاء الامي لم تعجبني الصوره بتاتا ولم
ارغب في رؤيتها مجددا لفتره طويله لمده
سنوات
اثر ذلك اكتشفت الحكومه الفيتناميه وقتها
انني انا صاحبه الصوره التي جارتنا على
صعيد واسع في العالم ارسلت وفدا يبحث عني
في المدرسه والمنزل ومن ساعتها بدات
تستخدمني وتضغط على اسره لاستخدام في
دعايتها السياسيه بالنسبه لي كانت حقيقه
منعرجا سيئا في حياتي في البدايه اعجبني
ذلك وخاصه كوني فتاه صغيره عاديه من قريه
مجهوله تذهب الى مدرستها بجروحها والامها
وعذابها وفجاه تسلط عليها الاضواء وتصبح
محل اهتمام الحكومه لكن لاحقا اصبحوا
الامر مزعجا وشعرت وكانني لم اعد املك
حياتي بتدخل متكرر في مدرستي واضرار الى
الانقطاع عن الدراسه فقط لتنفيذ برامجهم
الدعائيه ولكثافه نفود التي يستدعونها
لمقابلتي اضطرت الى الانقطاع عن الدراسه
ازعجني ذلك كثيرا لانني كنت ارغب في
التركيز على دراسه بعيدا عن كل هذا لكنهم
لم يرقوا بدلا لذلك